item number two relates to colin
kaepernick pete carroll the coach of the
seahawks the only team the only team of
the 32 that at any point over the last
three plus years has actually brought in
colin kaepernick for a visit and they
decided not to sign him they're the only
ones who did it the issue came up
yesterday when pete carroll spoke to the
media it's a fairly long chunk of what
he had to say but it's important here's
pete carroll talking about the status of
colin kaepernick
cap called me during the season before
that off season
uh and uh
he called out of the blue to ask me you
know for some advice about where he
would go next i was flattered that he
would even think to call me because we
never talked before that i could be
other than just you know greetings and
uh
and so i from that point i was kind of
rooting for them you know and hoping
that they will things would work out and
so when it came back around and i forgot
about it but we came back around and we
had a chance to visit him you know and
it came up
i was thinking okay this is an
incredible football player let's find
out if it could possibly fit football
wise and all of that and then also
because he hadn't visited anywhere yet
you know maybe this would help him uh
you know open up doors for him if ours
thing didn't work out and uh we had
great meetings um you know and i don't
know that i've ever explained it in as
much depth but we spent half a day
together he spent time with our people
uh throughout the building and uh in
almost a full day and he he was awesome
he he just backed up even more of the
play that we had seen in the character
and then in his smarts and his
togetherness and and his competitiveness
to the point where um
it was so obvious that he's a starter in
the nfl that this you know it was just
that's what i think i eventually wound
up uh
answering to you guys you know what i'm
saying to you guys that um
he was he's a dominant figure he is a
football player and that's how we saw
him and and the the fact that it didn't
work out it you know for us you know i
figured he was he's gonna wind up
starting somewhere for sure and it just
didn't happen so i
the rest of that story is is one that i
i regret that that didn't happen in some
fashion i wish we would have contributed
to it because the guy deserved to play i
thought at the time i just in our
situation as a backup man i didn't i
didn't feel it was right
at that time so i had to make that
football decision it was about our team
and in the situation we had our starting
quarterback and all of that and uh it
wasn't going to be that open competitive
situation that i'd like to think all of
our spots are because russ was such a
dominant figure and all that so anyway
that's what happened and uh uh i wish i
wish we people would have called me
during the time before we ever got him
in and said hey he'd be he'd be great in
your program he may not be able to play
the hero there but he certainly could
play for you i agree with that he could
play for us he could have been a
fantastic player in a program
unfortunately just didn't work out and
then when you look back i felt like we
missed the opportunity and so as i look
back at it i wish we could have figured
it out and known known what we know now
and give him the chance because uh you
know i would love to see him play
football those years
i appreciate the candor from pete
carroll very much shireen and i respect
pete carroll is one of the best coaches
in the national football league i still
have trouble three years later
reconciling that competition competition
competition vibe that he constantly has
with turning away
someone who would come in and at a
minimum maybe push russell wilson to
reach an even higher level i think there
was a deeper concern because of some of
the guys still on the roster in 2017 who
resent russell wilson that one false
move in practice one false move in a
game and there was going to be a
groundswell in the locker room to put
colin kaepernick on the field not just
on the roster be that as it may it's a
strong endorsement of colin kaepernick
from pete carroll at a time when
it's not going away this is action item
number two as al sharpton said the other
day colin kaepernick must be repaired he
has been damaged by the deliberate
actions of the nfl to freeze him out
because he's the one that made all the
other players aware that they have the
power to kneel during the anthem he's
the man who is most identified with the
movement he's the man who has caused the
biggest headache for the nfl and they
have frozen him out and everyone knows
it and this
this conversation with pete carroll from
yesterday between him and the reporters
maybe that begins the process of
freezing or unfreezing the ice
mike i listened to that whole press
conference yesterday and let me start
with i thought jimbo fisher talked fast
oh my goodness try to transcribe what
you just watched
it it was pretty difficult and and that
was just one answer of several questions
about colin kaepernick i mean he spent
probably four or five different
questions
being quizzed about colin kaepernick
including would you sign him this year
would you be open to that and you know
he kind of talked around that one and
and but there was a lot of conversation
about colin kaepernick during that
hour-long press conference a big chunk
of it was about colin kaepernick and the
endorsement from pete carroll is great
but somebody's got to step up and sign
him now pete carroll did say that he got
a phone call yesterday from a team
interested in colin kaepernick they
wanted to ask how did the visit go when
he visited there of course the only
visit that colin kaepernick has had how
did that visit go and pete carroll gave
him a glowing uh seal of approval so it
sounds like one team is interested in
signing colin kaepernick that whoever
that one team is or whatever team is
interested needs to step up and do that
have they called the agent we don't know
that
i want to hear that directly from pete
carroll because i haven't heard the
answer we have and i want to scrutinize
exactly what he said here because look
i'm always a little skeptical i'm always
a little cynical i want to hear what
carol said about a potentially
interested team here's the clip from
yesterday's video conference with
reporters
after all of the time that you know the
years that have passed
i never received a phone call about
about him i never talked to another head
coach about i never talked to anybody
about it until today
i got a phone call today i'm gonna tell
you who was but i got a phone call today
in in in asking inquiring about the
situation so i know you know
somebody's interested you know and uh um
and i and he you know so we'll see what
happens with that but i i thought that
was the irony of that was crazy because
i know i'm coming on your press
conference you guys can ask me a million
questions about this today i got a phone
call today for the first time
all right i believe him you know i
believe him i mean part of me thought
maybe he's just going to throw that out
there to try to pull the court on the
lawnmower and get somebody interested i
believe him i believe somebody called
him and i believe somebody is at least
doing their due diligence now i'd like
to know
does that due diligence include
contacting
kaepernick's agent contacting kaepernick
directly having a telephone conversation
he's a free agent you can you can do
whatever you want you can talk to him
you can bring him in you can do whatever
you want by way of doing your homework
on colin kaepernick and i i is there
trepidation that if somebody directly
reaches out to colin kaepernick it's
going to leak out and and i think that
that has been one of the reasons why
teams have shied away and again the
world has changed there should be
evidence of this awakening that the
world has changed and something i said
earlier in the week that the things that
previously would paralyze teams the fear
of alienating a segment of the fan base
because god forbid you're just
considering colin kaepernick that needs
to go away i want to see a greater
conviction a greater resolve and actual
courage from these teams to do the right
thing and not say well we can't make it
look like we're interested in colin
kaepernick because we don't want to get
a bunch of nasty emails and twitter
messages from our fan base that doesn't
like it you just need to do it if you
think it's right for your team if you
think it potentially makes your team
better you do it and the hell with
anyone who doesn't like it shireen
yeah and i think again mike you pointed
this out times have changed and it does
feel different and i don't know that
there's going to be protest and there'll
be some of that probably and there'll be
some people who say i'm never watching
an nfl game again i'm never watching x
teams game again i'm not supporting x
team i'm burning my jersey there'll be
some of that
but i do think this feels different and
i do think if a team signs colin
kaepernick i don't think it's going to
be with what it would have been maybe
even a year ago
i think this is different and if a team
signs him i think he's going to come in
and he's going to eventually after a
week or so be another player on the
roster and not just be
colin kaepernick this guy who's going to
cause dissension on your team i don't
think that's what it's going to be so a
team needs to
needs to have that feeling that that
they can sign him and things are going
to go well and and i don't know that a
starting quarterback is going to be
looking over his shoulder this guy
hasn't played since 2016. it's going to
take him time when he gets back in the
league
to
get back to the level that we remember
colin kaepernick if he can get back to
that level we don't know any of that we
don't know what kind of shape he's in we
think he is he he says he's been
practicing but there's a difference
between practicing and throwing to guys
and and playing on a football team at
practicing every day and playing games
and he just hadn't done it since 2016.
and there has to be the willingness on
one hand to do the due diligence bring
him in and if somebody doesn't like it
that's their problem and then there has
to be a willingness to cut him or
uh not sign him if you don't like what
you saw at the workout but i think the
standard needs to be relaxed this is
part of the effort to repair colin
kaepernick acknowledging that he's been
out of it for three years through no
fault of his own i mean mike vick was
gone for two years for something he did
and should have been gone for two years
and some would say maybe even longer
when you consider he could have been
prosecuted in virginia for actually
killing the dogs that were deemed unfit
to eventually compete
in dog fighting operations and the
eagles found a spot for him and the
eagles gave him that kind of transition
year before they they moved on from
donovan mcnabb and let mike vick compete
to be the starter so if you can do it
for a guy who was out for two years
because of something he did you can do
it for a guy who was out for three years
for something that isn't his fault for
something that is the fault of the
league for collectively freezing him out
and you know whoever would have a
problem with colin kaepernick coming
back to the nfl those people can huff
and puff all they want a lot of times
they huff and puff and they won't blow
your house down i'm never watching nfl
again when's the next game on the other
thing too is part of the conviction and
the courage and the resolve i want to
see from the owners is to say you know
what we don't want you if this is the
way you are if this is who you are if
this is how you are if you are part of
the problem in this country we don't
want your money we don't want your time
go do something else get out of here
right that's part of what i think
needs to be conveyed
in this moment if the fringe that
doesn't see things the way that everyone
else is seeing that and and that hasn't
had this awakening that now is the time
for true equality now is the time to
understand what the message was and not
complain about the method but understand
the method and what it meant to colin
kaepernick to be the person who who sent
that message i i i think that i think
the nfl's attitude should be we don't
want your money we don't want your time
we don't want your fandom go do
something else
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports